The joe rogan experience.
Really.
You put something in that book that really blew my mind.
You said that in 1975 and 76 in Hudson county where I'm from,
there was 40 car bombings.
Oh Man.
40 car bomb.
I remember one bombings,
not all car bombings in Hudson county from seventh street.
The 88th street there where you have bay on.
Oh,
boken.
That's up.
There was 41 car bombings system.
Correct.
In the 70s in the u s where bombings,
homemade bombs were like the preferred a weapon of organized crime.
There were,
there was a,
there was a bombing,
Warren Cleveland over this Irish gangster in the 70s.
It was
pretty common for Billy to,
they made a bomb with the nails to guy had gotten,
uh,
the Sicilians are good bomb.
They did make a movie about Danny Green.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What was that movie called?
Kill.
Kill the Irish man.
And now that we're doing it again while they're doing the Irishman,
a different movie.
Yeah.
It's fascinating stuff,
man.
Now,
did anything surprise you when you were,
you were putting me in,
obviously you're well versed in organized crime and well versed and these kinds
of things.
I think it,
uh,
the dominant feeling people have when they're reading this book is the dominant
feeling I had when I was researching,
which was,
why don't I know this shit?
I mean,
this is like really,
this is not only a great story really interesting,
but it's really important history,
all this political connection to anti-castro movement and the role the u s
government might have played in it.
And the idea that this criminal conspiracy organization was allowed to go on for
40 years because certain elements in the u s government didn't want to go after
them because they were afraid it would open the lid on the Cuban relations with
the sea,
the anti-castro relations with the CIA,
the politics of it.
That's,
that's,
that's not only interesting history.
It's important history to understand a certain social political relationship
between the US and Cuba,
the Bay of Pigs,
the residue of the revolution.
That's the way that shaped the cold war shaped us politics.
Over a period of about 50 years.
So I was like,
why don't I know this?
This is amazing.
This is like almost like a hidden history.
I mean,
I knew what got reported in the newspapers,
but you know,
you lift up the rug and you,
you look underneath the rug and you start to get into the details of it.
It just makes me so aware that what we're receiving as information on a daily
basis from the meat,
mainstream media and everything is a version of what's happening.
There's a whole other version of what's happening in that we don't see.
And you usually only find out about it 30 years later,
30 years after the fact.
And that's a good thing to know.
No.
Yeah,
I mean it sounds to me like this is,
uh,
I mean I've,
I haven't heard a peep about this.
I mean,
when you brought this up to me,
Joey,
and I was like,
what the organized crime,
the corporation.
What,
what is this like this is not discussed.
It's just not,
well,
hopefully this will change.
I grew up in it and I never talked about it because like I said,
I have a hundred stories.
We'd go for a ride.
I lose
a lot of shit.
I say him that I don't say it because number one,
you're not going to believe me and number two,
it's not my position.
I was raised enough for me to say,
you know what I'm saying?
Yes,
but I saw that as a child and then what made it worse than me?
It was moving to North Bergen.
Once I moved to North Bergen,
I saw
what they would do in union city in a bigger way,
which is all political.
I swapped things that are,
make it tone drop.
That's why I don't give a fuck about politics and the like,
well,
I see people talking about politics.
I want to go up to him and go,
if you knew what you were talking about,
you wouldn't say a word because you have no idea what real politics means,
how it works.
If it works like that in a micro system,
I can't imagine and a real so I don't want to pay attention to it.
Let me ask you a question because I,
I joined and I connected when I had more or less written this already.
Um,
if I had come to you way back at the beginning of this,
out of the blue,
all of a sudden this Guy Tj English,
I don't know,
you guess you knew the West,
so you knew who I was.
He knew I was legit.
If I had contacted you and said,
will you talk to me about this history when you have done it with everything,
I it would take us a week to debrief me.
So you would have been ready and we'll,
I woulda told you now you see what's interesting thing I would have known
because somebody's Hacia here,
this fucking story.
He opened up the door for me.
I have a responsibility now that I have another story to add to this.
Yes he does.
I have the nuts and bolts of how this works.
Have you thought about an addition to this?
I think there's going to be a number of spin off books from this.
This is really a book that comes from,
this is going to tell their personal glory shot.
I will end up dead.
Really,
Not because of the,
because of what I'm exposed.
The where we know who did it in,
in uh,
in,
uh,
you know,
I grew up,
when I was growing up,
the power in that Hudson county was the waterfront of Ge.
That picture in New York City that people see thousands of people died for that
waterfront.
That waterfront was controlled by Wheelock,
but everybody wanted a piece of it.
And North Bergen,
one of the piece of it.
So my eighth grade teacher was the Weehawken man.
You ever have a teacher that was a man?
Why would your teacher be a mayor of a town?
Why?
Why,
why?
Who's ever had a teacher tweet that was the mayor of a fucking town at the same
time I did.
And guess what?
At the end of my eighth grade year,
I show ATF come in and pull them out of that real,
I did 11 years.
Okay.
He doing,
he was selling the waterfront.
He all that,
that they knew that was miles.
There's a particular family that I will not mention because I won't even make it
to the four oh five and they were buying that property up.
Look changes 16 no,
no,
no.
They were buying that property up in the 60s they were posing as politicians.
They chop up 30 million a month now between four and then sell it.
No,
no,
no.
This is from all of the pop property.
They own it.
And Hudson county,
they bought everything.
Jersey City Hoboken.
They make their profit selling it.
No,
no.
They made them profit.
Renting.
Well,
renting it.
So the four of them before brothers Trump up 30 million.
They go their own ways.
Every month they chop up 30 million.
So I switched from North Bergen.
When I tell you stories about calm mind bows,
I know he was a cop.
He was a cop that I,
I got invited into.
He opened up his home to me and then his son died.
The one that was my age.
So I became a pseudo sun.
So here I am running with the Cubans during the week.
They're talking about numbers and drugs and everything and I'm growing up in a
cop's house.
That's also the driver for the mayor.
And he would do whatever.
Like I saw him handcuffed dude's and throw a beat on him and they called him
Vinny the tours they called him Karma and the torch.
Balzac no,
because his job was to burn your building down.
The last one he burned down.
Kids were like Mr Mr that smoke and he's like,
here's $10 who can ice cream?
I'll call the fire department.
He never called.
He faked a heart attack.
So you don't have to talk to reporters.
First thing you do is you fake a heart attack cause you don't have to talk to
reporters.
That gives you two days to get your story straight with the attorney that you
have no idea what I know now.
Now the reason I asked showing the question about what whether he would have
been willing to talk is a lot of people reached out to me early in this book
process.
The,
uh,
the,
the movie rights were optioned before I even wrote the book based on the book
proposal and that got a lot of media attention and I started getting emails from
nieces and nephews of sons and daughters of key characters in the story.
And these were people like Joey who had kept this personal family history is
bottled up bottled 30 years,
hadn't talked to anybody about it and now they saw I was doing this book and a
and I needed to get it off their chest.
They needed to talk about it.
I would go,
I met these two,
these two girls who were daughters of one of the guys who became a snitch,
testified against the corporation.
The family went into the witness protection program.
These girls had never talked to anybody.
When I met,
went to meet with them in a bar,
they weren't even sure they were going to talk to me.
We were just meeting to talk about whether they were going to talk
to me.
I got to meet them.
They talk nonstop for three hours.
Once they thought they could trust me,
they just,
they couldn't stop talking about it.
They had all the stuff they needed to get off their chest.
We were raised not to say,
oh Gosh,
oh gosh.
The first raid I saw,
my mother,
I was five.
They sat me on the couch and read it.
My mother had already thrown the coal golf about the total lady downstairs.
The landlord had already called and I said,
the cops are on the way out the door.
We lived on the west side,
terrorist facing a new New Jersey and the lady downstairs,
she would pay her rent and tell it,
hold this bag,
and my mother threw it.
They came up,
sat us down.
They asked us to leave with the 88th street,
88th street.
We never got raided.
When I moved to North Bergen,
I would get raided before I got raided.
The phone would ring and be calm.
My Masano tell your mom,
clean the house.
I'd wake my mom up to others to clean the house and come over here.
I don't want you to see what's going to happen.
Cops will come with the rest of my mother.
I would walk the coal mines house with my basketball right past the cops.
And it was that easy.
It was daddy's.
Wow.
Do you wish you ran into Joey before you started writing this?
It would've been a different book.
He wasn't.
Why I enjoyed this book so much is because no matter how much history this
motherfucker dropped on you,
he let you know Jose Battle was,
he kept you reminded who hosts a battle was that's big for an author.
He never got away from Jose Battle.
And when you read the book,
no matter what type of person you are,
you kind of get mad at Jose Battle.
But there's something about Jose bally away cause you didn't,
you want that guy and you go on it.
Okay.